القوات الأوكرانية تحاول ضرب
الروس على جميع الجبهات.
في ساحة المعركة ، أخبرنا الجنود أن
إطلاق النار يتم هنا إلى حد كبير كل
يوم عدة مرات في اليوم ، فالخط
الأمامي ليس بعيدًا جدًا عما نحن فيه على الإطلاق ،
إنه على بعد بضعة كيلومترات في هذا
الاتجاه ، والآن لا يوجد
الكثير من الحركة على تلك الجبهة  لكن
لا يزال الوضع خطيرًا للغاية
، قال وزير الدفاع الأوكراني إن
هجوم كييف المضاد هنا معقد بسبب
الطقس الرطب في المنطقة ،
لكن القائد يقول إنه يعتقد
في النهاية أنهم سيطردون الروس
لا
تتراجع أبدًا من هنا ، ليس لدينا
خيار آخر ، فقط إلى الأمام ، يتعين على أوكرانيا
استعادة جميع أراضيها وحدودها
بينما تواصل روسيا حشد
مئات الآلاف من أجل  الحرب
هنا يقول الأوكرانيون إنهم وجدوا أن شركة فاجنر
العسكرية الخاصة التي أسسها
بوتين ألي يفغيني بريغوزيان ترسل
سجناء روس مصابين بأمراض إلى
الخطوط الأمامية ، أخبر رئيس المخابرات العسكرية الأوكرانية
نيك روبرتسون مراسل CNN
أنهم ارتدوا عليهم بعض الأساور
باللون الأزرق الأبيض أو  يشير اللون الأحمر ، كل لون ،
إلى التهاب الكبد السل أو فيروس نقص المناعة البشرية ،
إنه يحدث على نطاق واسع ،
ومعظمهم ممن يأخذون سجناء أو
جثثهم التي تم العثور عليها في
ساحة المعركة كانت هذه الأساور
لا تستطيع سي إن إن التحقق بشكل مستقل من هذه
الادعاءات مع استمرار القوات الروسية في
التراجع.  في أوكرانيا ، أجرى الكرملين
تدريبات نووية سنوية ضخمة
تتضمن صواريخ باليستية تطلق من غواصات
وأخرى أطلقت من
أسطول القاذفات الاستراتيجية
الروسي ، بينما أبلغ الروس الولايات المتحدة
عن التدريبات قبل وقت طويل من قيام
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
بتحذير واضح لواشنطن
بما يحاولونه.  لتحقيق ما نراه
في مثال أوكرا  التي
أصبحت أداة للسياسة الخارجية الأمريكية
، فقد البلد عمليًا
سيادته ويتم التحكم فيه بشكل مباشر
من الولايات المتحدة ،
لكن الأوكرانيين على خط المواجهة يقولون
إنهم يقاتلون من أجل حريتهم الخاصة
وليس من أجل أي شخص آخر.